un petit détour chez nos voisins de
l'île maurice à présent c'est là que
nous emmène au de biker pays gerbe
léocadie et olivier hoarau de
l'association on the run il organisait
là bas une compétition amicale en
descente sur les pistes mauricienne
image et impression tout de suite
embarquement immédiat
on avait on avait eu quelques échos que
le vtt était en train de il y avait un
bon groupe de personnes qui étaient bien
motivés donc on voulait aller voir
comment ça se passait et puis dans le
but de faire des échanges lui de
rencontrer quoi de konink endosser un
spot de tous les gars
les mauriciens se rencontrent là bas
pour essayer de creuser des bosses faire
avancer un peu les tétées donc il ya
plusieurs plusieurs sentiers on va dire
puisqu'un peu plus typée four cross une
piste de dh et plein de projets
interrogé à venir c'est vraiment le
plaisir avant tout on peut vraiment se
lâcher il ya des sous qui sont vraiment
sympas et après le niveau de difficulté
c'est pas c'est pas énorme mais c'est
déjà beaucoup pour pour les moyens
qu'ils ont là bas et beaucoup de plaisir
des gens puissent plaisir
daniel une petite colline il ya plus de
dix ans et on va ramener un peu la barre
pour m
c'est tout
on essaye de promouvoir au maximum notre
association est aussi par la vidéo on a
travaillé cette année
beaucoup de fois avec sensation sport
d'ailleurs super et
on continue dans la lancée et on lâchera
pas pour l'année 2012
alors la compet s'était organisé par une
association de jeunes associations mtv
freeride débrouiller avec les moyens du
bord et de tout la compet c'était une
un dual c'est un peu un style fort cross
mais ajuste a2a pour la piste qui avait
et puis c'était aussi le moyen de
de regrouper tout le monde et créé une
petite cohésion de riders là bas et ça
s'est super bien passé
nous notre but c'est vraiment de
rassembler les gens passaient du bon
moment faire des belles rencontres et et
puis c'est vraiment partager cette
culture du reiki une culture événement à
part entière et qui a beaucoup de
valeurs et de principes auxquels on est
fortement attachée et des trucs sympas
comme le plaisir à coup les voici tous
bio bender oui merci beaucoup parce que
c'est eux qui font le show s'est incliné
qui ont mois et neo nous pousse à aso
curé notre association en lorraine pour
vous aussi et pour montrer aux gens que
avec un mais l'on peut faire aux mêmes
essayages
c'est
le
là